bella tutti ragazzi pervenuti a questo
video sono quello che fai videocall
ciccio che tenta di riconquistare i
quadri italiani dalle altre nazioni
però solo consigli solo potete essere
che un ciccio che ancora bannato dal la
volta scorsa quindi gioca che è stato
prestato l'argentina e roberto fanizzi
che ringrazio partiamo da parto io però
non mi far fare figure di mer senso non
ce la facciamo le partite visto che in
questa varietà vice di un canale pro una
pena di fare bene subito in attacco
subito in attacco te la butto in the
mezzo e vediamo di sognare salvo licata
sognavo un paio di cam aggrappato cg
latenza tendente a dattilo perché si
sente la forza di fila forte ma io lo
farò segnale potenziare palo interno
non so dove sia possibile rolex igno ci
riprova ma niente e allora prova a
ripartire dai pro farmi sognare
bye bye bye bella ely non entrano
lavoravo lavoravo racino se non l'hanno
lasciata tutti per nega tutti lanciata
ok daniela spingi spingi però senza tour
è così entrato come una perla lascerà
che tiro sotto al sette cliente non
riesco non si può segnare non si può
segnare però insieme alla base da
qualche modo tipo così bello abbiamo
fatto sanzioni amore è giusto che
segnino loro di miley mario raffa
madonna che mina tira la ciccia tua lo
tolgo tanto la bosnia ballo non ci credo
con loro non ci credo bro
il tutto permette ragazzi si appaia vero
oggi lasciata la palla lino demolito 1
hanno insegnato loro c'è pazzesco però
un mio amico che ha mandato se vuoi il
giapponese la traduzione di la monna
lisa è seriamente dell'italia
monari oggi senini white aria karate
tutto mentre dice vista stronzate
abbiamo questi dati metrici ste
stronzate 11 video di giocarla questa
per troppi fanizzi proprio lui che deve
ripetere mezzo però c'era l'ex cigno che
tenta il controllo e teri santa si fa vi
non ci riesce
non ci riesce quindi fa viva in difesa
spencer aspetta che questo patina figuro
2 bravo l'abi panizzi fatto io
lasciami partirebbero lasciami
controllare il pallone
lasciami segnare così lasciami segnare
così sporca la bellissima minuti
altrimenti mi stai facendo veramente
sudare buttarla in mezzo ciccio bravo
fra tutto lui ci c'è un fenomeno di una
fenomeni giapponese papa tipo tu
purtroppo ti sento del critico chiofalo
perché ho dovuto trip l'artista non
segnavo perché lì in mezzo con loro
l'oro mancato non è però affatto
sbagliato che hanno sbagliato tutto
sbagliato tutto sbagliato tutto
sbagliato non riesco a toglierà neanche
dal numero tutto sbagliato
lo dice da 65 volte poi vai vai avanti
bravate di mezzo che voi occhio vai non
ti parlava bene per niente e lui ti è
stato bravissimo meno male che non
scavalcato meno male che non scavalcato
occhio vai avanti in quello loro bulbo
mai notturno non so dove sia non può
fare nemmeno non la posso parlare perché
non è comparso un tubo in due ore
chi cazzo se la sentono rumori
tranquillo non ci venga detto stasera ha
preso di petto ne vado io
diciannove secondi dalla fine o presunto
che non dovevamo prendere che ora ci
faranno attenzione
eccolo qua l'altro sono da fogli dello
spirito roberto parizia lo spirito pro
provvista novità ci sta a monte della
città guardarla è tutto per rendere il
video più figo adesso è giusto che
segnino al 43 così buttiamo il video mi
hanno spinto mi hanno spinto non è turbo
no ti sei fatto superare prossimo andati
giusto già pronto ma semmai è sì by
paolo non hanno segnato come come che
corsa grazie ad un gesù cristo
abete riparto
o mio caso è bene che in questo senso
numerico ceo il massimo quindi ma quello
che succede in tutto a posto ragazzi
adesso basta
vai vai vai bravo ciccio roberto fanizzi
che ci prova e io concludo così il boss
ragazzi mi va di urlare dovete
trent'anni nella mia vita di carriera
della juve by roberto tirare in mezzo si
è partiti bene oggi
ora si è partiti barricano aspetta che
libro dell'occhio mai farsi prendere
l'occhio 13 pagamenti non ma grandi ci
penso io e 6 moss che non propone guarda
tutte queste può essere può essere
invece ma ti giuro che non so come mai
io sto giocando normalmente fa ragazzine
che mi sono entrate nelle giocate
speriamo che sul reddito così le due
vittorie del giorno ce l'abbiamo
no non ti fa scavalcare il mio berton
scaricare eccoti perfetta tranquillità
vado in porta ma nono turno evidente
radi devo dirmi l'ho saltato
vabbè però perché lui ha tentato di
demolirne ho dovuto saltarlo se non mi
avrebbe demolito e poi dovevo andare in
porta non potevo salvarla guarda va bene
niente
una colta lui è pazzo pazzo pazzo sono
partito benissimo sono pazzi questi il
controllo è incredibile è peccato dice
l'artista sono raccontano sicuro a
trento via cirano berto panizzi roberto
porca vacca fani xvi ok perfetto ma tira
tira tira gol negoziati
mamma mia che stavo sudando festa in
pace mamma cosa come i fan a noi voglio
vedere sto cosa faccio però questo
questo gol a privati è rimbalzata vabbè
diciamo che è sceso di nuovo signore ha
detto no
hai un avatar bellissimo tu devi segnare
che sono senz'altro grosso perché
buttare in mezzo
mammamia troppo e cioè adito a troppo
cuore
non me l'aspettavo neanche per sbaglio
però guarda lì non mi aspettavo neanche
per sbaglio è vero che ancora aspetta
quello dragato turbavano sull'altro
bella bruna vantino e avrei voluto
tirare da tutti in mezzo titolo ci sono
io no oddio mi sono scartato 1 sul muro
tirala no vabbè che succede bellissimo
bellissima melissa paris era troppo
convinto coste cosa facciamo
bravo lacera e let's go tira tira
bravissimo è nono turbo però cipro 1 non
ci prova fatto bene o male e la palla
rimane lì occhi proprio porta molto bene
molto bene grande spinta lunghissima
tira no ciccio voto and now aperto dai
the jacket e capisci che hanno sventato
primavera che ha detto no vabbè qua
moneta perché il dottor della o teq di
avere mai hai detto in chat questa cosa
qua fa sempre cagherà adosso di versare
effettivamente sono molto contento di
come i giocatori ciccio branze avrò i
meriti un po di iscritti il suo canale
lo trovate in descrizione per avere sia
piaciuto ragazzi che stanno i due
partiti dai circoli google ciccio
lasciate mi piace il chiedere a casa era
come sempre ci vediamo da ragazzi
[Musica]